Speaker 1: A Kerry Lake is in shambles.
As her opponent who won has been sworn in
as governor.
That's right.
Lawsuits and fundraising and donations.
And going to Mar a Lago has done nothing to
prevent Katie Hobbs from becoming the governor
of Arizona.
The lawsuits didn't work out.
The Associated Press reports Democrat Katie
Hobbs takes office as Arizona governor.
And why wouldn't she?
More people voted for her, and at least in
theory, the way our elections work is when
you get more votes, you get to win.
Katie Hobbs took the oath of office Monday
to become Arizona's 24th governor, first Democrat
to hold the office since 2009.
She was sworn in during a private ceremony
at the state capitol.
She formally took over from Republican Doug
Ducey.
Hobbs was surrounded by her parents, husband
and two children as she placed a hand on a
family bible and took the oath of office in
the governor in the lobby of the governor's
office.
In one of her first official actions.
She signed an executive order setting in motion
a process to update the state's policies barring
discrimination in state employment and contracting.
She's also adding.
She's adding.
New protections based on gender identity,
political affiliation, military service, or
veteran status, marital status, culture and
other characteristics.
She is the fifth woman to be governor of Arizona.
The last Democratic governor of Arizona was
Janet Napolitano, who resigned in 2009 to
become Barack Obama's homeland security secretary.
OBAMA We remember him.
We remember him.
So, listen, the lawsuits didn't work out and
they shouldn't.
This is what happens when you get more votes.
You win the election, your opponent loses
your of you get to play the role to be the
person who carries out the duties of the office
that you ran for.
Now, we have to understand, in a sense, Donald
Trump has ruined elections in that losers
still think they have a chance to win after
someone else democratically wins.
If they can file the right lawsuit, convince
the right person, get the right slate of electors,
whatever the case may be.
Now, Arizona didn't want Kerry Lake.
More voters voted for Katie Hobbs.
That should be where we move on.
So we have to get really serious about the
impact of people falsely claiming that elections
they lost are rigged and actually should be
turned over to them.
And Kerry late gave a couple of interviews
here and she's doing the entire Katie Hobbs
didn't really campaign thing.
It was like Biden and blah, blah, blah.
Speaker 2: Kerry, her former president, Donald
Trump, said anything about this?
It's all.
What has he said?
I've talked to him several times.
He was really pleased with our case.
He believes we have incredible evidence.
He was disappointed with the judges.
Speaker 1: This this was like a couple of
days before Katie Hobbs was sworn in ruling.
Speaker 2: And he's happy to see that we're
going to continue to appeal it.
He's feeling that America has become very
corrupt and I agree with him.
We're watching.
Speaker 1: He's the one who has corrupted
it to a great degree.
Speaker 2: This is Twitter as the Twitter
files kind of unroll a rollout, I should say.
And we're seeing how the FBI and other government
agencies are controlling our speech, censoring
us.
Speaker 1: The FBI didn't allow me to figure
out the difference between Latino and Hispanic.
They're patrolling our speech.
Speaker 2: Controlling a narrative to push
an agenda.
How the FBI was working with social media
to propel corrupt Joe Biden's campaign and
stop the America First movement by censoring
people who are trying to get pertinent information
out that would have opened people's eyes to
the corruption of the Biden family.
The FBI was behind that.
Our own government is trying to control the
outcome of an election that is criminal.
Katie Hobbs, is she nervous?
Is she worried?
She should be.
I mean, I know I know that Katie Hobbs knows
she didn't win this.
I know that Katie Hobbs knows she cheated
the whole state knows it.
The whole state knows this is a racket.
This is a joke.
She's a joke of a candidate.
And I don't know how she would even govern
because the state is not behind her and they
are losing control of their narrative as more
information gets out about how they ran these
elections, how corrupt these elections are.
She's a complete joke.
You know, she's couldn't even articulate her
policies.
She didn't show up to to debate.
She didn't even campaign.
She's our own.
We have our very own version of Joe Biden
here in Arizona, and her name is Katie Hobbs.
Speaker 1: What I love about that is these
right wingers who keep claiming, oh, Biden
couldn't have won.
He was in his basement.
Katie Hobbs couldn't have won.
She didn't even campaign or debate.
They should really be turning their gaze inward
to realize, wow, we keep losing to people
who we don't believe are even campaigning.
That's the humiliation.
Voters still preferred their opponents to
them, even though they, as far as their story
is concerned, red carpet campaigning while
Katie Hobbs is and Joe Biden's in his basement.
So bottom line, we got to get really serious
about what these false claims of rigged elections
do for us.
They undermine public trust in the electoral
process.
They can serve to suppress turnout, which
maybe is exactly what they want to do.
When you claim an election was rigged without
evidence, people start to distrust the process
and it makes them less likely to vote, which
maybe is exactly what they want.
That's been a hallmark of Republican politics
for a while.
Sometimes we see these claims incite violence
and civil unrest.
You look at January 6th when you make baseless
allegations that the elections were rigged
and you say Democrats took it from you and
from you and they threw your vote in the trash.
Some of those people get angry and they do
violent things.
That's what we saw on January 6th.
It can damage relationships with foreign countries.
Not that Republicans care, but if a candidate
or a political party says this was rigged
and it wasn't, and then at some point they
take power, foreign countries can look at
that and.
Say We're not really feeling like we are actually
equals here and that you wildly claim you
lost elections that you won, elections you
lost.
That's not a good basis for cooperation with
foreign countries.
And lastly, it just creates division and polarization
over lies.
It's unfortunate, but understandable that
if one person says abortion is murder and
someone else says abortion should be legal
in most cases, as most Americans do, that
would be a possible source of tension.
We would hopefully be able to talk through
it, but that's a logical source of tension
based on real policy differences.
If you falsely claim elections were rigged
and some people believe it, you're creating
that division and polarization with baseless
claims.
And we're polarized and divided enough.
I don't think that's necessary.
So these are all the risks and the problems,
and they need to be held accountable for doing
it.
Early attempts to sanction Kerry Lake have
gone, okay, but we really have to do something
about it and we probably need to do something
about it soon.
Next Wednesday, January 11th will be the first
Town Hall of the year, 6 p.m. in the east,
3 p.m. in the West.
We will be live and taking your questions
about 2023, 2024, whatever.
Everybody is welcome to call in.
Members will get priority and you can sign
up at join Packman dot com that will be streaming
live remember Wednesday, January 11th.
We'll take a quick break and be back after
this.
The David Pakman Show in this new year continues
to depend on your support.
We are really an audience funded program and
I would love for you to sign up at join Packman
dot com.
We do the daily bonus show for our members.
We offer a commercial free audio and video
stream for our members published hours earlier
than the show is otherwise released.
And when we do town halls like we're doing
next Wednesday, January 11th, our members
get a totally separate channel and priority
access to talk to me all of those things and
more sign up at join Packman dot com you can
use the coupon code 24 starts now because
it really does even though I know it's just
the start of 2023, this 2024 election is rapidly,
rapidly getting under way.
We'll talk about that a little bit later.